hier soll frank plock wunderschönen
guten morgen meine damen und herren hier
heute zu einem neuen blog ja dinge die
kann schon länger keinen block mehr noch
mal sagen wenn ich da etwas auf der
insel hat die heutigen blog meine damen
und herren während er in den zu acht
übrigens ihr superminister von de wir
werden heute in den zoo fahren meine
damen und her ist sieht so aus als hätte
ich rote haare gerade jüngere freundin
eine probe treffen
warum macht man wenn du kannst sehr gut
bester blocker oder
dr
habt ihr schon mal gesehen bei oldie
nacht hat es in köln einfach noch
geschneit habt ihr vielleicht weil der
instagram story gesehen
er schreit ich habe noch nie so richtig
stehen können gesteht und jetzt ist hier
einfach nur noch so regen hey was soll
die villa in der deko freunde ich habe
bock depot für eine bestimmte jahreszeit
zu machen deswegen habe ich die
weihnachtsdeko osterdeko und süßigkeiten
genossen bild muss schön sein eventuell
auch den video von vor zwei tagen
gesehen wo wir einem eckball das ist
euer kind erwarten challenge über kommen
dass wir sind jetzt produkte die noch
übrig geblieben sind die hat mir noch
tiefgekühlte machen wir mal waren dann
bringen wir das obdachlosen weil
weihnachtszeit auf räume was haben wir
denn da leckere ein hallo mein name ist
lukas wetter 14 gut was ganz schön hier
einfach was ich möchte
[Musik]
wie finden wir ja schön also zunächst
einmal nehmen das ganz auf die seite
dann machen wir das auch und ein paar
keine schade drin
[Musik]
diese filmstar ist die ganze zeit
ich mach doch hätte
[Musik]
was auf dass du nicht in den sweater
schneide stehen nur aus dem lukas
schossen das heißt ich gehe jetzt gleich
zu diesem jahr in pullach paket für dich
da ok ich muss jetzt ein paket für papa
abholen
ich habe das paket abgeholt freunde
wolltest du dich auch so richtig halten
auf was er sich am meisten hat mich und
hat die lacher auf eine im zoo
angekommen so freunde das immer bei den
ersten tieren angekommen
unity machen gar nicht kann es jetzt mal
da reingehen kann man ja jetzt seine
hand hoch und wir uns jetzt grüßen oder
irgendwo hab ich denn hin gelegt meine
fresse daraufhin ein buch von lukas
direct münchen heißen erdmännchen weil
es sind männer die erde in diesem gehege
meine damen und herren soll irgendwo ein
wildes luca buch zu sehen sein
bekommen mannschaft das haben wir denn
da ich so mehr an die oder ist es
[Musik]
sehr gut simba alles was das licht
berührt das ist unser königreich würde
meinte gerade das nicht mal könig der
löwen geguckt hat und weiß dass simba
kein gepaart ist hätte dieses video wo
so ein kleiner panda sich so voll
erschreckte nach hinten rüber fällt das
ist die kleine freunde erlebt gesunden
gegen dazu und sie süßes er denn es
erzählt die wälder ich bin gegen die
abholung der wälder hier da war der
versteckt sich gerade die polizei da hat
sich eine dachterasse von seinem
penthouse schmeckt einfach so ein salat
velcom traurig mal zu springen kleiner
panda
nein er ist schon wieder was zu fressen
so stehen und was kann er nicht schule
möchte mich heiraten kleiner panda oder
läuft wieder aus dem bild heraus ok
schutzfrist ich keine ahnung was das da
vorne für komische tiere sind aber sie
steht am müll einfach direkt hat mir
wieder vorne haben wir den buckingham
palace diese beiden leute davon in die
das spazierengehen sind einfach gerade
mir vorbeigelaufen beide durchgängige
kommt die pokémon co gespielt das spiel
schon pokémon go
ja jetzt kommen die bestimmt an mich als
verifiziert hat so wie vor europas der
schweiz und ist drei große wirklich an
der stelle anmerken kölner zuges kann
ich da in der politik endlich dann
werden durch diese kleine schnur und
also die laufen kinder herum
es geht einfach nicht und irgendwie tun
die mir verleiht diese stehen hier um
alleine in ihrem gehege stehen unterm
mistelzweig das heißt er muss jetzt
einen küssen hey kleiner mann oder frau
ich weiß nicht ob es da hinten sind ja
zebras neue juli wie nennt man es wenn
man ganz nah an einem zebra vorbeiläuft
zebrastreifen bruder meine wohnung putzt
mit einem tanz ich meine heißt nicht
ohne grund staubwedel wer also heißt du
doch oder
es hat echt schlecht dass der tiger
dahinten seine ganzen bierfässer einfach
hier in seinen sie schmeißt mülltrennung
wege also es ist vielleicht ein bisschen
riskant was wir gerade machen aber
united gerade löwen den frischen geht
die puste aus einfach wieder atmen
bruder ich habe keine ahnung wo wir sind
aber es ist hier so heißt auch man sieht
uns richtig gut da oben sind affen
freunde wir haben sie endlich gefunden
unsere vorfahren youtube sich die
scheibe laufen irgendwie ich weiß nicht
was der affe da oben macht aber ich
glaube
für uns gibt es ich hasse spinnen und
ich würde mal ganz durch die linse
glaube damit ihn wirklich genau sehen
können was wir hier gerade vor uns haben
und bei einem ornament vorne spielte
hier nicht immer girlfriends
hält den eigenen amerikanischen rapper
ja einfach einzusperren brudy ich weiß
nicht ob du irgendwie ausgebüxt ist oder
so aber ich glaube nicht dass er sich
einfach so rum la es wird mal wieder im
rennwagen
[Musik]
tschüss brody freunde das sind
elefantenbaby im gegensatz zu mir sogar
schon ein tannenbaum julia wiemann
schneemannbauen für mich bitte danke
danke du hast ihn verstehen sogar so
perfekt informationen
da liegt eine menge scheiße überall rum
pinguin ja du warst du ich hab noch
einen pinguin hier bei meiner seite ich
hab noch ich habe nein nein nein schwein
die machen halt alle gar nichts ich weiß
noch nicht was bei ihm ja abgeht aber er
findet die steinmann anscheinend sehr
interessanten der da vorne auch also
freunde ihr könnt auch einfach kraft auf
youtube schon ein bisschen ok freunde
wie den ganz klar einen atem vorgang
also erlebt auf jeden fall noch also
macht euch keine sorgen als setzt ist
hier meine damen und herren sehen sie
hier noch die leucht bahn an
ich weiß nicht was das für ein gesicht
ist
luca fragen sind wir nicht weiter
sondern die ministergärten
alles gekauft außenminister cannon
wunderschön estate hier mit zwei
burritos doppel date wir sind wieder zu
hause angekommen und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen abschließend zum toten
tiere waren primär eigentlich am
schlafen oder die von uns einfach zu
hässlich und sind dann abgecheckt von
anfertigte hässlich oder halo entwickler
älter ist die nordsee zu schwimmen gehen
das ist nicht gesponsert oder irgendwie
sowie komplette freizeit also zunächst
einmal habe ich mir 420 den großen
glasboxen gebraucht weil ich dabei der
ganzen konto mit anlage werde dann habe
ich mir noch eine riesige schüssel
gekauft zusammen mit zwei würfeln
ja ich wollte geld ausgeben
doch seine bosch gekauft meine ist
jacques wir kommen jetzt habe ich meine
ganzen drogen sortiert rein dann habe
ich mir hier noch vier fleißig gekauft
damit man nicht kleckert während man
gucken kurs gekauft weil dagegen dass
bäume und papierverschwendung hier noch
klein
der zucker behältern ist wirklich für
zucker haben wir noch eine teekanne und
verpackt man hier
marianna rein und dann kann man spaß war
aber oh mein gott beschenkt jahren
natürlich auch abgekauft
die geschenke für die familie hat sich
ganz schön hören
dann bist du gut ist weil damen und
herren ein ständchen was ich nicht mal
wieder mit ihren familien werden
ja das hat es hier vollkommen verband
lasse zu sagen es uns getroffen
ich würde an dieser stelle dem blog
jetzt allerdings auch beenden bei der
damen und herren
der sollte eigentlich heute nur
abspielen was gute kameraposition der
blog heute hat er eigentlich nur von der
zur sache handeln als ich wollte in das
anfangen zu und auch schon beenden damit
zu er kann ich allerdings zu einem
kompletten block daraus gemacht ich
gesagt okay allerdings gefallen
natürlich mich sehr sehr wohl bei einem
daumenbruch folgen da noch
weihnachtsgeschenke verrichten machte
die ganze familie und sonst meine damen
und herren mit dem web laufen wollen
scheint doch noch in die kommentare
[Musik]